verbal tennis have you guys diamonite
now I have animal tennis and it's
basically a game in which each player
must respond with a question raw can't
make it you can't repeat it's kind of
like this where'd you get that shirt and
then you can answer why do you like it
and then I have like how could I not
what do you think of the color and ok I
get it
that's cool I like that uh so we can do
both play us play off against you Martin
and then we'll see who wins
ok I care that works us two versus
Martin this Sameach
well you're the guest so I'll keep
school Martin how did you start YouTube
I'm ready bad at this uh didn't didn't
we talk about this ready ah there we go
didn't we talk about it so come on it's
supposed to be snappy and fast that's it
sorry I was rubbish I was relation
question
stop it yeah why don't you use your kid
Martin looks like a little turd I don't
know do you have an answer for that
maybe but I think you should ask
yourself why you look that way is that a
statement or a question ah well I didn't
hear what you said I've laughed too much
is that a question I don't know what is
a question I ask myself that every day
do you like the statement that's gotta
be a point to be dyed that's it bad this
games really let's do one more sign up
to me mine ok terrible um hey Puetz I
mean you got two dogs and why your your
dog hater well I don't really hate dogs
what do you think about cats you don't
like cats do you I do but what do you
think about spotty ones wait I think
we're going with two sorry we and I'll
share two sentences it's just one
sentence like I always say stop making
statements the beginning sorry
oh is that how you did okay yes so bad
at this ken fights a minor
tensile plate is so hard I'm like oh my
god okay Ken can you you're the expert
you do it against my not yeah yeah okay
Martin do you like my shirt oh yeah it's
nice what color is it
that's that works right are you
colorblind
I'm not why would you ask that why don't
you know what color my shirt is because
it looks a little bit green doesn't it
like I could do it this is like ha ha ha
ha ha ha and just going into it I don't
even a lose you win